more now on the british monarchy as king
charles adjusts to his very new role
this morning we're reflecting back on
the family
lineage that led to this moment
interesting fact but for a twist of
history king charles would not have been
in line to be the monarch why
well vladimir dutier who considers
himself an expert in many things he's
now an expert in royal history too who
knew this about you vlad good morning
it's not just now gail i've always been
a royal nerd because it is living
history and it is very very fascinating
yes i perhaps know a few too many
details but they come in handy for this
story i took a look at the history of
this family's liliach and you'll see
it's rich in twists and turns
as the world mourns the death of queen
elizabeth ii it feels nearly impossible
to imagine a change to the monarchy
after her 70 years on the throne queen
elizabeth ii represented stability to
britain and to the world but at the time
of her birth princess elizabeth
alexandra mary windsor was never meant
to be queen here's why when king george
v queen elizabeth's grandfather died in
1936 his firstborn son king edward viii
ascended the throne but a controversial
romance with american divorcee wallace
simpson put an abrupt end to a reign
that lasted just 325 days divorce was
still
something that was not done and it
certainly wasn't a common practice for
monarchs so he was given a choice
give up the love of his life or give up
the throne
the king chose to abdicate in his palace
the king was about to address the
nations a few hours ago
i discharged my last duty
as king and emperor
which thrust his brother george vi who
was also elizabeth's father into the
spotlight the nation believes that when
i
i speak i speak for them as featured in
the movie the king's speech george vi
was merely just despair a man with a
stutter a fear of public speaking with
no desire to be king i asked you
to join with me
in that act
of thanksgiving but he forged ahead
fulfilling his duty and preparing his
firstborn child elizabeth to one day be
queen that included serving in the
women's branch of the british army
during world war ii the 25 year old heir
was touring kenya when she learned her
father had died it is very clear that
she understood that her life would be
dedicated to service she took it very
very seriously i declare before you all
with my whole life
whether it be long or short shall be
devoted to your service
enter the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
it's a very complicated legacy even for
a lot of africans but washington post
columnist karen atiyah says the imperial
family and its colonial subjugation of
lands and people was not something to be
celebrated even under her reign there
was the mao mao rebellion of kenya for
instance which was a colony under the
british at that time which the british
violently crushed put kenyans into
concentration camps evidence of torture
of displacement which to this day the
survivors and the descendants are
seeking damages from the uk for that in
her global travels queen elizabeth never
publicly acknowledged the monarchy's
often brutal colonial past
and over the past few days many people
around the world have expressed
resentment towards the woman who
symbolized to them the systems of
oppression and force extraction of labor
why should we talk about it now the
reason why we haven't been able to have
proper conversations about
britain about the royal family about the
symbols of white supremacy and
colonialism is because those discussions
have been whitewashed erased and
sabotaged despite the complicated
history of the monarchy there is no
doubt that queen elizabeth ii was a
beloved monarch evidenced by the people
from all over the world who've made
their way to england to pay their
respects to the queen who always said
she was merely a humble servant
and there have been other royal twists
of fate when she was born elizabeth's
great-great-grandmother that's victoria
was fifth in line of succession for the
throne behind the four eldest sons of
king george the third the death of
various princes and a lack of male heirs
resulted in the princess capturing the
crown arguably changing the course of
history and here's how her descendants
kaiser wilhelm ii of germany and brazar
nicholas ii of russia and king george v
all wage war against each other during
world war one millions of lives lost
setting the precedent for world war ii
and the world that we live in today wow
george v was her grandfather i still
marvel that she was 25. it's interesting
when you see the complicated history
there right but she was 25 when she came
on the throne and said i promise whether
it be long or short i will serve to the
end of time people say well she should
have addressed that and she never did
she never publicly addressed it um and
she never you know there will be some
people who will understand that she saw
herself as apolitical and others will
say that's not true she could place a
well directed call to the pm if she
wanted vlad we appreciate you for the
history lesson thank